Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Yes, what a surprise, because it's like, why would Dookie put Street Fighter 6?
Like, why would she stream Street Fighter 6 so willingly?
Like, wow!
Could it be that she ends the Sajam Slam again?
Yes, that is right.
I will be participating in Sajam Slam 3.
For the Street Fighter 6 arc.
Yes, we're back in our FGC arc, guys.
Okay, I just need you guys to know how we're so fucked.
Like, the moment I got into the server, the Discord server, everybody was playing.
By the way, I didn't buy Street Fighter until like last night, by the way.
But yes, for like, I saw Street Fighter.
So many people just grinding Street Fighter for like the entire, like, week.
And I'm like, okay.
I'm so fucked.
Like, we all know I'm gonna be in the beginners category.
But do you also know who else is gonna be in the beginners category?
Yes, SK and Goomy.
They're back.
They're gonna be back in the beginners category.
And I'm like, I was like talking to Sajam about it.
I was like, for those who don't know, I was in the last Sajam Slam for Tekken.
And, you know, we won.
We got champion.
We won.
And one of the victories that got us to the final, like, got us the first place was that I beat SK.
And like, I basically beat the fan favorite that was supposed to actually win.
And I still don't know how.
I still don't know how.
SK, she kept playing Tekken right after.
I haven't.
Guys, ever since the last Sajam Slam, I have not touched Tekken since then.
But SK has.
I was like, oh yeah, Sajam, do you know, like, who else is gonna be, like, beginners?
And then he was like, oh yeah, you know, SK and Goomy are back.
And I'm like, okay, wait a minute.
I'm just like, okay, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
And I was like, wait, isn't that a little, you know, you know, like, Goomy, yeah, she's the beginner.
But like, SK kept going.
I mean, she kept going.
And then Sajam was like, oh yeah, but like, you know, they're still beginners in Street Fighter.
And I was like, yeah, but they're fucking grinders.
I don't, I don't even know if I have time for that.
Like...
They're just gonna be...
Even during Tekken, all they did was grind Tekken.
I just learned...
I just know five moves.
And I'll...
My entire strategy...
My entire strategy going into the last Sajam Slam was four moves.
And then during the tournament, I learned a fifth move.
And I think a sixth.
I don't remember.
I learned a fifth move during the tournament.
I literally have a 38 in defense.
So...
So I was just like...
I was like, oh no.
I'm gonna have to fight her again.
I'm gonna have to fight...
Fight the same people again.
So yes.
The reason why, for those who don't know.
The reason why I am playing Street Fighter VI.
I'm streaming Street Fighter VI.
Is that I got invited to do a Sajam Slam.
We're running it back.
I want you guys to know.
Also, like, give me a sec.
My soundproof thing fell, fell off.
I need to get like an adhesive spray.
There's this one corner in my room.
It just always falls.
It's so annoying.
Like the...
I use the...
Oh my god.
It fell.
It fell while I was trying to...
Give me a sec.
It fell while I was ranting about it.
And plugged it in.
Okay.
Alright.
I need to grab like an adhesive spray.
Yes.
Of course I'm gonna play Modern.
Guys.
I've literally...
I literally found out that there was like two different sets of controls.
Like I...
We're not super gluing.
Cause I...
I don't own this place.
I'm ranting.
Also, Scott.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so happy you're playing this.
And on my birthday.
I hope you have fun.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Scott.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Yes.
Of course.
I'm gonna do Modern.
Like...
I literally found out what the difference was between Modern and Classic.
I think like an hour before the stream.
And I was like...
Why is there two sets?
It's a Contrast.
Um...
And then...
And then they were like...
Oh yeah.
Like...
You know...
Modern is for the beginners.
And I was like...
Yep.
That's me.
I'm...
I don't need any ego or anything.
Um...
I'm just...
I'm...
All I'm saying...
It's like...
I don't care.
Like...
You're like...
Oh...
You're gonna be a Modern player.
I don't fucking care.
Like...
I am going in with zero experience of Street Fighter.
I have a...
I have an excuse to do Modern controls.
Like...
I'm going in there with zero experience with Street Fighter.
I'm not gonna make myself have a more...
A terrible time.
I heard Classic has like 200,500,000 moves.
Modern is just like...
You know...
Half of that.
And you know...
That's still a lot.
But like...
It's...
It's at least less than that.
Like...
So apparently...
I found out...
That...
The...
Difference...
Between...
Uh...
Modern and Classic...
Is that Classic players have to do...
More moves...
And you have to do more inputs...
But Modern...
Has something...
What I like...
Called...
Auto combos...
And like...
You know...
I like that.
I like automatic stuff.
Like...
The future is now.
We're not here...
To go back...
Into the prehistoric times.
This is...
I...
I don't need an ego boost...
To be like...
Yeah...
I'm a Classic player.
I am here...
To like...
Uh...
You know...
I...
I am...
I am baby.
I...
I know my place...
In this world.
I am literally...
A baby.
The only Street Fighter experience...
I have...
Is...
Uh...
Street Fight...
Like...
Is Marvel vs.
Capcom.
I've never played...
Uh...
We're...
I've never played a Street Fighter game.
So...
This is where I'm...
I know where my place is at.
But...
Doki not a real game, man.
Look...
I don't tell you guys.
You've seen my controls in Tekken.
Like...
You know I have no idea what I'm doing.
I...
Uh...
Don't worry.
I do not feel bad using modern controls.
Like...
I know my...
I know...
The thing is...
I have no reason to be an elitist.
Because I'm a...
I'm a fucking baby.
I know my place.
I'm literally...
I'm not even in Kindergarten.
I'm not even in preschool.
I'm still in the womb.
I'm like still in the FGC womb.
Okay.
Alright.
I also want you guys to know...
I almost dropped out.
I was...
I was literally...
This close...
To dropping out of the CHM Slam.
And...
The only reason I dropped out of the CHM Slam...
The only reason why I wanted to drop out was because the timing for the Slam was so bad for like everybody in Team Brawl Pro.
Like literally...
Like...
Brawl Pro stayed in the tournament because of me.
Cause...
And I stayed in the tournament because of Brawl Pro.
Cause I was like...
Cause...
Like...
Everybody was so busy.
Um...
Everybody was like super busy for like in Team Brawl Pro for the tournament.
And...
Um...
And it was just so bad.
Like...
Literally...
Kony DM'ed me two weeks ago.
And was like...
I can't wait to be on the same team again, Doki.
Yeah!
And then...
Last week...
I got another message.
It was like...
Oh, fuck.
I can't do it.
And I was like...
No!
What?
What do you mean?
He was like...
Oh...
I can't...
I can't do it.
It's during like literally his vacation.
Um...
It's like vacation days.
And he has a child.
Like...
Some of the...
My team members...
From Team Brawl Pro...
They're like...
Actual dads.
Or like...
Old.
So like...
Um...
He couldn't like...
Cancel his vacation.
Because he has a child.
It's not like he could be like...
Yay!
I'm gonna cancel this vacation and play video games instead.
Or that child's gonna grow up with daddy issues.
So like...
Obviously...
He couldn't do that...
To the kid.
Um...
He has to spend time with his kid.
So...
Um...
So he couldn't make it.
Similar with like...
Slime and Matt.
They actually had like...
Something...
Around...
These times.
So like...
Um...
Yeah.
He has to be like a responsible father.
I know it's...
It's hard to...
It's hard to see that.
Because you know...
It's...
I know it's very rough to imagine.
Because some of our dads are still trying to get milk.
And stuff.
Um...
Anyway.
Similar with like...
Matt and Slime.
They actually had...
Like...
It was literally like...
The same...
Um...
What...
They had like...
Prior obligations.
Um...
So they can't...
Do Sajam Slam.
And I...
I was this close.
I was like...
I...
I know...
Okay.
So like...
It was...
It was such a hard decision.
Like...
Um...
Because you guys know.
I...
I signed up for the Slam.
Only because like...
I wanted to run it back.
With...
Team ProlPro.
And I've been saying that since the last Slam.
Like...
I was like...
Okay.
I'll...
I'll come back if like...
We're all back together.
Tight deal.
Because like...
It was like...
It was so fun.
You know?
Like...
Um...
And then...
Like...
Before like...
Uh...
Before we like...
Knew what the schedule was like.
Matt and I were both like...
Oh...
I don't want to make new friends.
I'm scared.
I don't know anybody.
And I'm like...
What if we don't vibe with the new people?
I...
I was like...
I was so anxious and scared.
Because I was like...
Oh...
I'm nervous.
Like...
Ah...
I knew how Team ProlPro was gonna be like.
Before.
Like...
When I picked...
I wanted ProlPro as my coach.
Because I knew what that team was like.
Uh...
Before.
Because I watched their vibes from the first Slam.
So I knew like...
Our vibes...
Would like...
Match up.
And I've known about them for like...
About them individually.
In like...
The streaming community.
But for this one...
I'm really scared.
I have no idea who...
A lot of these people are.
Like...
I...
I think like...
I don't know who like...
90% of people are...
In the Sajam Slam.
So I'm like...
So anxious and everything.
Because I was just like...
Oh my god.
Ah...
I have to...
Meet new people.
What if we don't vibe?
I know...
Uh...
Brawlpo...
We requested each other.
And Sajam told me...
They're gonna...
He's gonna put both of us together.
Um...
So like...
Uh...
We're both gonna be on the same team.
So like...
We don't have to worry about that.
Like...
We literally stayed...
We literally stayed in the tournament.
Because like...
Um...
Uh...
Like Brawlpo was actually...
I think like Brawlpo was one...
Was thinking about dropping out as well.
And then...
He was like...
Okay.
I'll stay.
If you're staying.
And I was like...
Oh...
Okay.
I guess we're both staying.
I guess...
And...
Um...
But yes.
I was like...
I was super...
Nervous and stuff.
And...
Um...
I'm just really anxious now.
When it comes to like...
Meeting new people.
So I'm always like...
Super hesitant about it.
Even my like...
My manager team was...
My manager team was like...
Oh maybe...
I mean...
If you're really stressed out about it...
Maybe you should drop out.
And then...
But I...
I decided to stay though.
I decided to stay...
Uh...
Because I know...
How much like...
My Dragoons were really...
Like you guys...
Were like...
Really looking forward to see me back in...
Sajam Slam.
And like...
I saw like...
So many people were like...
Adding Sajam.
And being like...
Oh I wanna see...
Doki Bird back.
I really wanna see Doki again...
In the tournament.
I really wanna see her play more fighting games.
And...
You know...
I can't really stay...
In my cumbersome...
Forever.
And like...
To grow...
I have to be willing...
To like...
Take risks...
And try new things.
Like...
So that's why...
That's why I'm here.
I...
Will...
Get out of my...
Introvert...
Little...
Area...
And interact with...
New people.
I...
Will...
Socialize.
Okay.
Alright.
Now for the part...
Where a lot of you guys...
Are here for.
Because of my...
Pinned message.
I...
Will address...
The elephant...
In the...
Room.
I also typed this out...
Because I don't wanna...
Accidentally go off script...
And like...
Get people in trouble.
So...
I will address...
The elephant...
In the room.
And...
I've asked the organizers...
And Sajam...
If I could talk about it...
And they have like...
No problems with it.
So...
I wanna talk about it...
To make sure there's no like...
Rumors...
Or like...
Speculations going on...
During the tournament.
Especially...
Before like...
The team announcement.
So you might have seen...
Like...
People who are participating...
Um...
In this current...
Sajam Slam.
Um...
If you guys don't know what the fuck is going on...
Good.
Okay.
That doesn't matter for you guys.
Like...
You guys can like...
Um...
Just be like...
I don't know what's going on.
Like...
Oh well...
That's okay.
Like...
It doesn't matter for you guys.
But for those who do know what's going on...
This is...
I'll...
I'll talk about it.
Um...
Okay.
So...
Apparently...
The conditions...
That...
They gave...
The organizers...
Was that...
There has to be...
Zero interactions...
Between me and them.
That means...
We won't be on the same team...
And they will not be in my skill division.
Obviously...
I'm gonna be in the beginner level.
And also...
I'm gonna get like...
Absolutely destroyed.
But...
They...
Will not be in that skill division.
So...
We will not fight...
1v1.
And...
Uh...
Sajam...
Even asked...
Me...
If I was okay...
And...
Comfortable with it...
A few days ago...
And if I was...
Really uncomfortable...
And stressed out...
About the whole situation...
They won't let them participate.
I was honestly like...
Really surprised...
That he even...
Gave me that option...
Since this was like...
The first time...
Anyone has ever like...
Asked this of me...
And like...
He didn't have to do that...
And I won't lie...
I was really anxious...
But I said...
It is...
Not fair...
To kick the player out...
When...
They were not involved...
And...
Or responsible...
Especially when I know...
They are very passionate...
About fighting games...
And the FGC community...
Um...
And...
They really want to be here...
I will not take that away from them...
And we all know...
That...
I suck at fighting games...
And me...
Getting kicked out...
Won't really matter that much...
In the long run...
So...
Like...
I was like...
So I was like...
I was honestly like...
Really surprised...
That Sajam...
Wanted to make sure I was okay...
When it was really just...
Easier to ask me to step down...
Instead...
And...
Uh...
Like...
I've been outcast before...
I've been ostracized in the past...
I was even denied entry...
For tournaments and events...
In the last six months...
So like...
I know how it feels...
To be like...
Excluded...
And I don't want that...
For others...
Especially...
If the event...
Is something they are passionate about...
So...
I told Sajam...
That we shouldn't take away...
Their chance to participate...
And ruin...
Their experience...
Due to the actions of others...
And...
Like...
I'm going...
So like...
Basically...
I'm going in...
There's gonna be...
Like...
I know like...
Going in...
There's gonna be like...
A lot of reactions...
When the announcements came out...
So I just had to...
Basically...
Uh...
Mentally prepare myself...
In advance...
Type deal...
Which is fine...
Like...
I knew in advance...
And I just had to like...
Mentally prepare myself...
And like...
Just like...
You know...
Um...
Had...
Have like...
Like...
Make sure...
That no one's gonna get in trouble...
And that starting here...
There will be...
Zero interactions with them...
As per the rules...
And...
We're just gonna...
Vibe...
And have...
Fun...
Okay...
It is a...
For fun tournament...
And I'm here to have fun...
And...
This is...
Will be the last time...
I'm gonna talk about it...
Going forward...
And it'll be the last time...
I'm addressing...
The elephant in the room...
Type deal...
Uh...
So yeah...
Yeah...
Basically...
That's...
That's the scripted portion...
Over...
Like...
Scripted portion...
Done...
Like...
Now...
It's back to...
The usual...
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
I really wanna show you guys something funny...
So like...
Obviously...
I don't know who the fuck to play...
Uh...
I...
I don't...
I don't know who to play...
And like...
When I got into the server...
Um...
I...
When I got into the server...
This is what I wrote...
I was like...
I need to show you guys this...
So I was like...
I'm here to vibe...
It's not yesterday...
By the way...
Like...
I screenshotted this...
On the day it was yesterday...
This was like...
Not yesterday...
But...
I saved this screenshot...
This was like...
A couple of days ago...
Um...
I was like...
I'm here to vibe...
I don't know what's going on...
I don't know what I'm doing...
And...
I just wanna play a character...
That beginners hate playing against...
And everybody's like...
Bison...
What do you mean that's...
I literally played King...
Like...
And then...
And then a coach was like...
Okay...
And then the coach was like...
If you wanna ruin someone's day early...
On Honda...
Bison...
J...
I don't know who these characters are...
By the way...
Uh...
It was like...
Honda...
Bison...
JP...
Lily...
Gil...
Blanca...
I know Blanca...
Blanca's the spiky guy...
I know that...
Um...
And I was like...
Nice...
Use that information responsibly...
No...
A fucking question...
I'm here to...
I'm here...
I'm here to cheese my way out of the assertive...
Um...
Coaches wise...
BP and I...
Bravo and I...
We're like...
Talking about it...
And like...
We might...
Request...
Brian...
Um...
Okay...
I...
This is like...
This does not come from me...
Okay...
But like...
Um...
Bro...
Cause like...
Obviously...
Bravo knows more about the fighting game community scene...
And...
Um...
And like...
I was...
So he was like...
Asking around the street fighter scene...
Like...
In his area...
In his local area...
And was like...
Alright...
Here are our coaches...
Um...
Like...
Who should we get?
And then...
Um...
Like...
He was like...
Who is the funniest?
And then...
No offense to the coaches...
It was like...
But like...
The local players...
Was like...
Honestly...
None of them...
I was like...
No...
What?
That sounds so
mean...
I was like...
Holy shit...
That's so mean...
But...
They were all saying...
Like...
Um...
If I...
We want vibes...
We should try...
Uh...
We should...
Why do you...
I'm here to vibe!
I'm literally here...
I'm literally here to vibe!
Like...
I know my place!
I'm in the beginner division!
Like...
Me as the player...
Whoever team I get...
They're...
Like...
I'm like...
The mascot...
Like...
I'm not...
I'm not real...
Like...
I'm literally...
I'm literally like...
The mascot...
Like...
Of...
Uh...
Of the team...
They're just like...
Oh...
You did great sweetie...
Like...
If I lose...
They're like...
It's okay...
You know...
Like...
It's expected...
If I win...
They'll be like...
Are you...
Did we get the right person?
Like...
If I win...
They're just gonna be like...
Alright...
Who's actually using your controller?
Like...
So like...
I know my place...
Like...
On...
On the team...
Um...
It'll just be like...
A very pleasant surprise...
When I do...
If I do win a game...
Uh...
Expect...
Just remember...
Expectations...
Are...
Very...
Low...
Um...
But yes...
Uh...
Most likely...
Brawl Pro and I...
We're both gonna...
Request for...
Uh...
Brian...
And then...
We'll see how it goes...
Like...
Um...
I don't know...
Anybody...
Honestly...
I didn't even know anybody in Tekken...
I just was like...
Oh...
Hey...
You played...
Brawl Pro plays King...
And I wanna play King...
So like...
Obviously it worked out...
But like...
Now I'm just like...
I don't...
I don't know...
I don't know what I'm doing...
Um...
Anyway...
Let's actually play the video game...
Street Fighter time...
Yay...
Alright...
Here we go...
Also...
I have...
I found my level list controller...
Also...
Guys...
Um...
If we get to the finals...
I will beg Seijam...
To let me have Kony...
Be my substitute...
And have him cosplay as me...
Cause the finals is at TwitchCon...
And like...
Like...
Kony's down...
He's so fucking down for it...
And like...
I know like some of you guys are like...
Yeah...
But...
Like...
Kony's so good at Street Fighter...
I will...
I'll make him play the worst fucking character in Street Fighter...
And maybe play...
And play on classic controller...
Cause he's not good...
Alright guys?
And he'll...
There's no way he'll learn in time...
And I will be...
And also I will ask him to be drunk too...
Maybe...
I will just be like...
I will be like...
Um...
Be drunk...
Play the worst character...
Play...
as classic...
And then...
Because he needs to be at my level...
He needs to be...
Cause like...
The actual rules...
Was that...
I can play this and...
I can't play this...
The actual rules is that they have to be on the same... be blindfolded!
Okay, I'll also tell him to be blindfolded.
Only if I make it to the finals.
Only if I make it to the finals, chat.
Um, I will make Kony cosplay as me to participate as me at TwitchCon.
We're just gonna throw as many debuffs and invert the controls.
Yes.
I'll make him play with inverted controls as well.
blindfolded inverted controls Okay, but I have to make it to the finals.
That's the thing.
I The only stipulation is that I have to make it to the finals.
Really I
Even told BrawlPro.
I was like please carry me I was like only, you have to...
I was like You have to carry me to the finals, because Kony will cosplay as me.
And then, and then, Brapo was like...
Bro, I haven't even played this game in a year and a half, man.
He's like, I haven't touched this game in a year and a half.
Like, I don't know what you want, but it does sound really funny.
Like, he's like, it does sound very funny.
Okay, I'm raising up the volume.
Alright, what do I do?
You know what?
Let's go.
What's the worst that could happen?
I have no idea how to play this game.
What the fuck is the worst that could happen?
Alright, what are we trying?
What are we trying, guys?
I can't lose Elo.
I'm literally at the bottom.
Guys, I'm at the fucking bottom.
How would I lose Elo?
How?
How do I even start?
How do I queue up?
How do I even...
On?
How do I even queue up?
How the fuck do you... pause?
How...
You just do...
Oh, I'm queued?
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Placement matches.
Like, what's the worst that could happen?
Master Lee, you're giving a master rate when you reach master rank.
Okay, that's never gonna happen.
Alright, I am a beginner.
Yes.
No, don't worry.
I know I don't need a change.
Alright.
What's the worst that could happen?
What's the...
Can't be that bad.
Alright.
Oh, it's the CPU.
It's the CPU.
This is fine.
What am I doing?
What am I...?
Oh, shit.
Oh.
How do I...?
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I'm doing it?
Is he...
Okay, he's doing it too?
There's no way I'm going to lose to a CPU, right?
I think I might lose to a CPU, guys.
I don't know what I'm doing.
What's going on?
Wait, is this like...
Oh...
Okay, wait.
No, no, no, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay, wait.
Oh shit, I figured it out!
I don't know what I did!
That's right, get CPU'd!
Dodge?
What the fuck is dodge?
Okay, don't worry guys.
Don't worry, I figured it out.
I don't know how I did it.
But I figured it out.
I'm doing a thing!
Alright.
I found the grab!
Oh, what am I doing?
Nice, we did it.
We did it.
No CPU's going to beat me.
No CPU.
Wait, I didn't heat burst?
The fuck?
I almost forgot what a heat burst was.
It's been so long.
Oh.
Wait, did I block it?
I did!
Oh my god, the block animation is so weird.
The block animation is so weird that it...
I can't...
I didn't even...
Like, I can't figure out what I'm blocking sometimes.
Oh, I parried?
Oh my god, I'm doing it!
Woah.
Okay.
Wait.
CPU shouldn't be allowed...
You're level 5!
How do you know how to block?
That's all I'm saying.
All I'm saying is that...
As level 5, you should not be allowed to block.
Like...
You should not be...
No!
Alright.
I don't think Honda is it.
Honda...
Honda doesn't seem to be, like...
Oh shit!
Wait!
What?
I'm doing it again?
No, I want to pick a different character!
I don't know what...
There's st...
I forgot there's stamina in this fucking game.
Like...
The Dark Souls it.
The Souls like it.
Alright.
I don't even know what's using...
Oh, that's using the stamina.
Oh no, empty.
Oh.
No, am I blocking?
Am I blocking?
Guys, rank is not as intimidating when it's like I'm literally fighting a CPU.
Like...
It's not as intimidating as, like, I think it is.
When my first game is literally against a CPU.
Okay.
Nice.
It's just one hit!
That's right.
Pretend you're a shapeshifted Wukong.
Use the power of the Salus Monkey.
Zane, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Not nice.
Oh, no.
Oh, please.
Why does he know how to jump?
You're a computer!
Oh, no.
Out of...
What am I doing?
What am I...
Why can't I...
Why is he so fast?
Get out!
Alright.
Nice.
I'm using my Loveless Controller, by the way.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what?
Oh.
Did I do it?
What did I do?
I just...
What...
What did I...
I did something.
Oh.
What did I...
What is that?
Oh, I move!
You can't do this to me!
Oh...
Yay!
So easy.
That is...
Wow.
So easy.
You know what, maybe Street Fighter isn't so bad.
I mean Street Fighter seems so fucking easy, not gonna lie.
Stop pretending, Toki!
Okay, let's go to... let's go to... let's go to training.
Let's go to training.
Alright.
Uhh, training room.
So, alright, another suggestion people told me to try was Bison.
Wait, do I have to buy Bison?
I have to buy... I... what?
Okay, wait.
I thought I bought the Deluxe!
What do you mean?
What do you... you have to buy Bison?
Like, I... I bought the fucking... I bought the entire Deluxe!
I paid a hundred bucks!
A hundred plus dollars!
Like...
I'm fighting instead of Season 2.
You mean Season 2 is not included?
Like, I bought Season 1?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, so I paid a hundred... yes, this time I actually bought the game instead of, like...
I asked them, like, if they could give me a free copy, but they're like, no.
They're like, no, you gotta... you gotta buy your own copy, dokey.
Like, lol.
So...
I can't believe it.
Guys, I need to... I don't remember my PayPal email.
I need to look it up.
I was... I thought... I thought I didn't have to buy it!
I thought... why did I pay so much?
What's the point?
The real fight is the microtransaction.
Curse you, microtransaction.
Why did you make such an OP character?
And then put it behind a paywall?
Alright.
I can't believe it.
Agreed and paid.
Oh my.
And before, like, I don't even fucking...
Okay.
Ooh, authorized.
Stereo.
And before, I don't even play him.
In the end, just like Eddy.
It's just like Eddy all over again.
Alright.
We got Bison.
We got him.
Alright.
Bison isn't that good?
I heard he's a noob killer.
That's what I need right now.
I need the noob play.
Which one?
Please read this.
Can't go wrong with Zangief all skin number nine.
Thank you for the super chat, Savage.
Thank you.
Am I even on modern controllers?
I can't tell.
Oh, I am.
It says M.
Alright.
What am I doing?
Alright, guys.
I think I'm like...
I'm doing it.
Am I still?
Oh, I'm still in rank Q?
I'll never get out of rank Q.
That's how you learn.
Like this?
This is how I won...
This is how I won the King...
The King V Reina fight.
All natural.
All natural, baby.
How is she so fast?
That's right.
I used to play Starcraft.
All natural APM.
She's so good.
Alright.
Let's see.
Whoa.
Hey, that's a sick move.
Guys, I won't learn until, like, I actually win.
I actually have a coach.
That's how it happened with King.
All I did was spam inputs and somehow win.
Alright.
She's taking on...
She's holding and using the heavy attack.
Try holding the right trigger and using the...
Which one's the heavy attacks?
Is it square, triangle, O, X, R1, L1?
Oh, what's L1?
R2?
Or L2?
Oh, L2 is the grapple.
Oh, it's a circle?
Okay.
Right trigger.
Oh, it's a circle.
Is it this?
Is...
Okay.
That's the kick.
Alright.
L...
Blue is L.
Yellow is M.
Red is...
What the fuck are these num...
What do these...
What do these colors mean?
Alright.
NPC number five.
Come in here.
Oh, wait.
He's real.
Wait.
Rank up?
Rank up.
It's just like... what do you mean rank up?
I'm a baby.
Wait.
Why my Honda?
No!
I was landing bison!
Oh my God.
He knows.
He fucking knows.
Oh my God.
He knows I'm a baby!
Bro, this is fucked.
This is actually fucked.
This is actually...
Why am I on the right side?
Why am I on the wrong side?
I should be able to pick a side!
Get out!
Fuck you!
He fucking knows!
He knows I'm a- What the fuck!
He's actually beaming me!
You fucker!
I hate you!
You don't pick sides in Street Fighter?
What is this bullshit?!
When he's letting you win a round!
This is fucked!
This is so fucked!
Please don't do this to me!
Please don't let me win!
I don't wanna be higher ELO!
I don't know what I'm doing!
What the fuck!
Why are you doing this to me?!
No!
Just...
Why?!
I'm sitting around!
No, don't let me be higher, Rick!
I don't know what I'm doing!
No!
Why would you do this to me?!
I don't know what I'm doing!
Okay...
Alright...
Open matchmaking...
Oh, I have to like, re-select a character?
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'm ready.
Alright...
It's a nice fight.
I have to charge?
Is this charge?
Is blue charge?
Where's blue?
Blue?
Road to Master?
Oh, now you gotta match?
How?
How do I match up?
You open matchmaking settings.
Oh, on.
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
I've learned Bison.
Here comes a new challenger!
I've done it!
Hold R2, then press light, medium, or heavy.
R1...
R2?
Okay, R2.
Round 1.
Alright.
That's working right.
That's right, I don't know what I'm doing, but that's fucking right.
Oh, you're a CPU, what?!
They already gave me another CPU?!
I was so confident!
I was gonna be like, oh my god, I hit...
Oh my god!
I was so confident, too!
I was like, oh my god, I...
I've managed to like, you know...
Got so many moves!
Holy shit, I'm so...
So good!
Only to find out I'm in a... I'm in another... Oh, new character, new rank.
Oh, yeah, I forgot!
When you're playing a new character.
Why am I on the... Why am I on the right side?
Okay, R2.
Okay, R2, this time.
Oh, no, not this time.
No!
Goodbye!
Yes!
I got a hit in!
Oh, no, I... Yes!
Oh, I got another hit in!
Oh, no!
Get off me!
Okay, now... What?
He punished counter!
Guys, I think this is harder than Tekken.
I think this is actually... Guys, this is... Guys, Bison is harder.
Bison is so...
Why did I... Why did I decide... You know what?
Maybe I am a Honda player.
Maybe... Maybe I am a Honda player.
Alright, nice.
Should have gone with Ki.
No!
No, quit.
I quit rank match.
Alright.
Wait.
Maybe... Wait, I know!
Guys, I know now.
Guys.
Maybe I was meant to be a...
Zangief.
That can't be that hard, right?
That can't be... Oh, wait.
Wait, how do I...
It can't be that hard, right?
Do a tutorial.
Enzi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, you all know...
You all know...
Even when I do the tutorial... I'll do the tutorial, but it's not gonna go in the right ear.
Alright.
Whoa, what am I doing?
Whoa!
Wait, maybe...
Wait, maybe I'm a Ki player.
Oh, this is the most damage I've done!
Okay, wait.
Oh, God.
Wait, he's doing... He's doing stuff.
What am I doing?
Oh!
What did I do?
What am I doing?
Wait!
Wait, Enzi, could it be?
Am I a Ki player online?
Could it be?
Nice read.
Thank you.
I totally read that.
Very intentional.
Very...
I read...
I'm just a grappler main.
That's fucking right!
Oh!
Wait, I counted!
Wait!
I think...
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, guys.
Guys, I think...
I think I was just meant to play this character.
I think...
I think I was meant to...
I think I was just meant... meant to play Keef.
That is it.
I think this is it.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I think it's fate.
That was actually the best I've ever done.
I think it's the best.
It's just King with...
I don't know all the characters.
I've actually won a game against the CPU.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh!
Look at that!
I have no idea what I'm doing!
But it's working!
Oh, wait.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Wait.
Nice.
I don't know what...
I don't know what that move is, but nice.
And I haven't used up my stamina, too!
Oh.
I'm sorry.
Yes!
The grappler.
Oh.
Please.
Please!
Please, CPU!
Where?
Oh.
That.
No!
Oh.
Please!
Yes!
One Messiah!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Of course, the King player plays Zangief.
Who saw that coming?
Guys, I figured it out.
I was...
I was a Zangief player all along.
I'm here to grapple my way to victory.
Slap!
Game 2.0 here.
Oh.
There we go.
Come on.
Kick!
Where am I doing?
No!
Why did you jump?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
He's literally me.
Teacher Haggin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We told you Gief was the King of this game and you didn't even believe.
I believe now.
We figured it out, everybody.
We actually figured it out.
Wait, how do I change?
Oh, okay.
Where is he?
Is it there?
No, not keep!
No!
Wait, why not?
Why not?
Why not keep?
I don't understand.
Do not listen to sound, guys.
Let's go, chat.
Keep, keep, keep, keep.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
He is not a great player, but have fun!
No, don't say that!
I thought he was good!
What do you mean?
Is he not good?
Modern people carry a victory.
We only care about...
Guys, am I throwing?
No, there is no way.
Am I throwing my player?
Guys, I might be throwing my player.
There is no way.
You just got to be patient.
What the fuck?
How do you know how to count your throws?
We are babies!
I don't understand.
How are you able to count it?
I barely know what I am doing.
Are there...
Are there even beginners?
Nice.
Okay, thanks for jumping there.
I really...
You know, I do appreciate her jumping though.
I really appreciate that.
He is fine though.
I know why she jumped.
Oh, it's okay.
She is a real player.
What a read.
Guys, I can't believe I read her perfectly.
Guys.
Oh my god, she is so fast.
Why am I so slow?
Oh my god.
That's fucking right!
Get read!
I don't know how, but like...
That's fucking right!
This is embarrassing for you!
More so than it is for me!
Oh god.
This is more embarrassing for you than it is for me.
I am just saying.
That's fucking right!
Oh god.
Okay.
That's fucking right!
This is so embarrassing for you!
The fact that a real player lost to me!
What?!
I should have game!
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Guys, I don't think I am going to win this other round.
Guys, I don't...
I don't think she is too...
Oh my god.
Guys, she keeps backing away.
I don't know why.
Oh my god.
Guys, what do I do?
What do I do?
Not flawless!
It's okay!
It was not flawless!
And that's all I wanted!
I did it!
No flawless for you!
It's alright.
There was no flawless.
That's okay.
Just don't fight.
Just pray you don't fight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh no, you are not farming me.
You are not farming me.
How do I grab?
Is it this?
Let's just grab.
How do I grab you?
How the fuck do I...
Okay.
What?
Crap.
What's SP?
Guys, what is the SP button?
What is LP?
Guys, I have square, triangle, X, O, up, down, left, right.
You guys got to be very specific.
You guys have to be...
You guys have to be incredibly specific there.
The other tutorial.
But like, I'm winning!
I'm not winning.
But I like to...
Why am I fighting iron?
Oh no.
She knows.
Now she definitely knows I don't know how I play.
I'm doing great, right?
Oh shit.
No!
Alright.
It's okay.
Trial and error.
And we'll figure out grab.
This is how I've done it before.
Oh, I think I figured it out!
Trial and error!
I'll figure out grab by trial and error!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, nice.
Not nice.
Actually, it's not nice.
It's not nice anymore, guys.
It's not nice.
Okay.
Oh.
No!
How does she punish?
Do I hit this?
No, she definitely blocked that.
I didn't...
I can't believe Toki has gone to the deep side.
I'm shaking and crying.
Wait, no!
No!
No, Dwight!
You cannot have fun farming me!
Please!
No!
I'm a one and done!
How dare you trick me into getting farmed!
You know the best part?
That we don't have frame drops.
That's the best part of all of this.
That we don't have to deal with the frame drops anymore.
Alright.
Nice.
That's fucking right!
I learned how to grab, bitch!
I need to start.
Remember, stop doing the parry shit.
Guys, this is not...
This is not button mashing friendly.
Beefcake enjoyers.
Win again.
I keep accidentally glowing!
I can't help it!
The button is so close to the other buttons!
Alright, it's okay.
I can learn.
If I can learn King...
No.
I can learn Keef!
It is possible!
I got that one win!
Guys, remember that one time I won that one round against the real player?
Those were the good old days.
That was fucking wild, guys.
That was actually fucking wild.
Oh!
No!
So close!
No, the other one!
The other one!
Okay.
You are not...
You are not firing me.
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna go to the tutorial now.
I'm gonna...
I...
I guess...
I think this is the moment where I have to go to the tutorial.
I need to know what the other buttons do.
Alright.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Let's get started.
Wait.
I don't care about these guys.
Walking.
Alright.
Are we doing it?
There is no farm.
Alright.
Wait.
Keef can dash?
There was no dashing in Keef.
Keef's dash was literally one...
He literally walked two steps.
Wait.
This is classic?
Okay.
No.
We don't...
We don't do classic in this town.
Alright.
Where is... Where is modern?
Oh!
There we go.
Okay.
Alright.
Now we're... Nice.
Nothing is different, but like we're finally in modern.
There we go.
Dashing.
Alright.
Nice.
Keef... Yeah.
Keef's dashing is a fucking walk.
Alright.
To perform?
What?
First jump.
Oh.
This is jump.
I have to look down.
I forgot what controls.
Alright.
Nice.
Guys.
I learned how to jump.
Normal attack.
Alright.
Modern champion.
X.
Which is X?
Okay.
X.
Nice.
I did it.
Give me Keef!
I don't care!
I want to train on Keef!
I'm using X!
This is X!
What?
Wait.
Which one's...
Which one's mine?
But the X isn't on the X on my controller.
Is that square?
Wait.
Oh.
That doesn't make any sense.
That doesn't...
How do I change that?
How do I keep changing that?
Why am I on X-Box?
Okay.
It's square.
Oh.
Okay.
That makes more sense now.
Alright.
Okay.
Which one's A?
Is A X?
Okay.
A is X.
Oh.
Control mapping.
Okay.
Alright.
We gotta figure this out, guys.
Edit control.
Wait.
How do I change...
No.
I wanna... How do I...
How do I change it so that...
Okay.
Alright.
X is...
What is X?
X is square, right?
X is square.
Oh.
No.
Restore.
This is not it.
You can't.
I can't?
Wait.
Oh.
This is gonna be very difficult.
Which is B?
What is this?
Oh.
Okay.
I gotta go to the main menu.
I was gonna be like, this is...
This is not it.
This is not it for me.
Alright.
Tab.
Okay.
Option.
Alright.
How do I make it so that...
So that I'm...
I'm on the...
Uh...
Which one is it?
Oh.
There it is.
But how do I change it?
I don't...
I don't want it to be Xbox.
How do I change that?
Other outputs?
Oh.
Type 2.
I did it.
Nice.
You guys are so smart.
Alright.
I figured it out.
Now.
Now we're... Now we're okay.
Alright.
Practice.
Tutorial.
Alright.
Modern.
Okay.
Now.
We're going... We're gonna learn how to walk again.
We're gonna...
We're gonna learn how...
We're gonna learn how to walk again.
We're so bad.
I accidentally pressed... We went all the way back to the beginning.
Alright.
Dashing.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I told you.
I know my place as the baby.
I know my fucking place.
Alright.
Uh.
Nice.
Normal attacks.
Alright.
Okay.
Square.
Nice.
I forgot where the square was for a second.
Uh.
X.
Medium.
Alright.
Heavy.
Circle.
Oh.
Heavy.
Okay.
And then.
I could feel strength.
Thank you.
Wait.
What's this?
Oh.
Crouch.
I did it.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh.
Attack.
Okay.
Attack while crouching.
Alright.
How do I?
Wait.
What?
What am I supposed to do?
Wait.
What am I?
Jump attack.
But he's not jumping.
How am I supposed to hit him?
Oh.
Okay.
Sorry.
My timing.
I might have the fastest APM in the world.
But like the worst timing.
I might not be very good at timing or anything.
Okay.
Nice.
That was easy.
I can do that.
Give me my 38 defense.
Okay.
Crouching.
I do not have rhythm guys.
Okay.
What?
I can't.
I'm crouching.
Okay.
Okay guys.
Alright.
Throws.
Oh.
Square.
At the same time.
Or L2.
Okay.
L2.
And then.
Press square.
And X.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
I didn't read that.
What did it say?
Oh.
Okay.
Those are great options for.
Alright.
Special moves.
Now let's talk.
If you're playing Luke.
Pressing triangle will perform.
Okay.
I got this.
I figured it out guys.
I think I'm ready for rank again.
I think I'm.
I think.
Guys do you think I'm ready?
I think I'm ready for rank.
Now that I've learned.
You know that combining will let you perform different special moves.
It does.
Now that I've learned how to throw.
And.
How to throw.
Perform level one.
What the fuck is N?
There's an N button?
What the.
There's.
What.
There's no letters.
In my fucking controller.
Oh.
Neutral.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh.
N is neutral.
Okay.
I was gonna be like.
Where the fuck are the letters in my controller?
Where's the letter N?
Okay.
That's the other one.
I'm gonna press the.
Oh.
Okay.
Down.
Alright.
I figured it out.
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna like forget all this but I figured it out.
Beast mode baby.
Alright.
The drive gauge.
How do I use.
Oh this is the one I've been using.
This.
This is the one that kept fucking spamming.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
So it can absorb two attacks.
Oh okay.
You use it to break through an attack.
Okay.
Oh god.
Alright.
That can.
They can break corner opponents.
Press L1 to perform a drive.
Okay.
Nice.
We're doing it.
Next.
Roll R1 down.
Oh this is the one I love.
The blue.
This is the one I kept.
Oh shit.
This is the one I kept spamming.
Nice.
The blue.
Guys.
Would it be lying.
If I say I'm a speed reader.
And that's why I skip a lot.
While drive pairs are probably.
I already know that.
Alright.
Uh.
Yes.
Hahaha.
You don't know that.
I can speed read.
But I didn't say I'm good at it.
Okay.
You can try to defend against with.
I never said I was a good.
Speed reader.
There we go.
Nice.
See.
That's from my speed reading.
Haha.
There.
Of course.
Do a good defense is a good offense.
So you can counter a drive impact with one of your own.
But can lead to some big damage.
Okay.
Didn't we just do this?
Oh.
Okay.
Guess not.
I guess not.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Okay.
There we go.
Red and red.
Blue and blue.
Burnout.
Oh.
This is when you use it all up.
Wait.
What?
Oh.
Okay.
When you enter a burnout.
Oh.
So I do that when there's burnout.
Okay.
Battle end.
Now let's go over the rules of engagement.
Alright.
Yeah.
I did it.
Wait.
Is that everything I need?
To know?
To win this game?
Is that it?
Guys.
I think I'm ready.
I think I'm ready for rank.
Hahaha.
Yes.
Guys.
I think I'm ready.
I think I'm ready for rank now.
Like.
Watch this.
I learned this.
And then I learned.
I learned how to throw.
I learned how to do this.
Look at that.
I know that does that.
And I know this throw.
This is all I need for game.
Right?
Good on you.
I have the winning formula.
Good fight.
Look.
He even said good fight.
Alright.
I'm ready.
It's over.
It's so over.
Guys.
Hahaha.
For them by the way.
Not for me.
For them.
It's so over for them.
Hahaha.
Wait.
Kill me.
Hahaha.
How the fuck.
Fuck.
I actually couldn't.
I can't pay attention now.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
I can't even focus.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Sorry.
This is actually fucking hilarious.
Like what are the odds that we can win to each other.
Hahaha.
What the fuck are the odds of that.
Oh my god.
Hahaha.
Guys.
I think she actually knows how to play this game.
I think she like knows.
I told you guys.
Hahaha.
She knows it.
They are all crying news.
She actually read the tutorial.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
How did she know.
How did I.
Oh never mind.
That's how.
Hahaha.
How do I do shit.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
I know how to throw.
Hahaha.
That's all I'm gonna do.
That's right.
I know how to throw.
The only moves I know.
Hahaha.
That's right.
Get grappled.
Hahaha.
Get closer and I'll grapple you.
Oh never mind.
Don't do that.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
I will come back to throw you.
That's fucking right.
Get grappled.
I will keep doing it too.
Hahaha.
Oh no.
That's not what I wanted.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Hahaha.
Get grappled.
I defeated a real player.
I left.
Hahaha.
The first real player.
I beat.
Hahaha.
Get grappled.
You were the first real person.
I beat.
I hate you.
Hahaha.
Why did you rematch me?
I hate you.
Hahaha.
Bye.
The first real person.
I beat today.
Hahaha.
Because I think I'm meant to play GEEF.
No rematch.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I'm a GEEF player.
Oh.
Guys.
Don't GEEF.
Because I think Zanky.
Okay.
Do we get Zanky or don't GEEF?
What are we?
Alright.
Is there like...
Okay.
No.
I like the red.
There you go.
There's no more.
Hahaha.
No GEEF.
I can't believe she was literally the first player I won.
And all I did was this.
And literally all I did.
Hahaha.
Alright.
New challenger.
Going all the way.
She's asking Twine how to beat me.
Hahaha.
I think she was doing real combos too.
I think that was like...
That was the funniest shit.
The fact that she was doing real moves.
I'm just like, grappa.
Oh, oh no.
Grappa.
Okay, it's fine.
Bro, you're gonna let me grappa, right?
Oh no.
Oh shit.
Oh, hey there.
That was an accident.
Grappa.
That's all I need to know.
Oh shit.
Maybe not.
Maybe that's not all I need.
Oh no, he got me.
He got me.
Somebody stop.
How do I not do enough damage on him?
Is it because he's buff?
Does like size change the amount of damage he takes?
Oh shit.
It's not fair.
Get closer so I can do this.
I need you to get closer.
Oh.
No.
He didn't figure it out.
How does he figure this out?
It's okay.
It's the moral victory that I've had.
How did he figure it out that I only know two moves?
That's actually crazy.
Grappa.
You're not supposed to adapt.
Gumi didn't adapt.
It's all downhill from there.
He's rookie two no longer.
Oh my god, no way.
We're one and done.
He used it.
I can't believe it.
By pressing triangle?
Okay.
This.
Alright.
Ohhhh!
Okay.
Triangle.
Alright.
We figured it out.
We figured out other triangle moves that we can use.
Alright, this.
Okay, we gotta do this triangle and then this triangle and then...
Oh, now you're playing Geef.
Okay, we figured it out.
We're so ready.
Hold R2 triangle for more damage.
Where's R2 triangle?
Oh, there.
Alright, we figured it out guys.
It's so over.
Even Brawl Pro is playing Geef.
New move unlocked.
Oh my god, I figured it out.
I can't believe they wanted me to play Honda.
I can't believe it.
They wanted me to play Honda when I could just do this.
How do I do?
How do I level 3 again?
Was it...
No, that's not it.
I'm trying to remember.
How do I do it again?
Oh, this!
Whoa!
Triangle circle.
I don't know your style.
Grandpa!
Hello, Grandpa.
Alright, I figured it out.
Okay, I'm ready.
What the fuck?
What the fuck did he do?
What?
Guys, maybe now I... guys...
Guys, I think I know why...
I think I know why they want me to do Honda.
How do I get close?
What the fuck?
He didn't get in.
How do I get in if I can't even make it through it?
Grandpa's making so I can't touch him.
Grandpa, please!
I need this Grandpa.
This is not fair, Grandpa.
What?
How do I...
How do I block?
Oh, jump?
You have to jump in?
Okay, I almost killed him, though.
Actually, I almost killed him.
Welcome to JV.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
What is this bullshit?
You have to let me get to you!
Can't let me get to you!
Oh, no.
He grabbed me.
This is anime, Sony.
This is so fucked.
This is actually so fucked.
Get down!
That's right.
It's time to retire, Grandpa.
It's...
I need to unbind the...
I need to unbind...
Let me get close.
Let me...
Ow.
Go, start timing.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please, you got to let me grab.
You got to let me grab.
I'm going to unbind the Perry button.
Welcome to the real world.
I'm actually, only Perry.
This is the real world.
Bro.
We have sent out Grandpa to open Power methicon.
Past retirement, we're gonna buy a coffin for that grandpa.
I need to learn.
When you say aware, prepare, you jump.
But there's a different projectile with a different voice line.
I hope to god nobody is smart enough to learn grandpa.
I hope to fucking god nobody is smart enough to learn him.
That was actually bullshit.
How do I time that?
I don't know how to time.
Timing is so hard.
Oh Akuma.
Is that Akuma?
Wait, not Akuma.
Oh yeah, it is.
Is Gumi still raging?
I'm literally in another game.
How is she still raging?
I'm literally in another game right now.
Let me grab you!
Grab!
That's right.
Oh shit.
You fucking know I wanna grab you so badly!
You know this is all I know!
That's fucking right!
That's literally all I know!
Alright.
Lose don't lose.
I can't help it.
He's so fucking...
He's so rangy!
Wait, he grabbed me?
I grabbed you!
That's...
Oh.
That's right.
I must hit...
It's okay.
We're fine.
No, we're not fine!
We're not fine!
It's okay.
We're fine!
We're still fine!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
No!
He is the Shadow Man!
Not the crap dead dead!
I'm dead dead!
Yeah.
Oh come on!
Let me fucking grab you!
This is all I want!
That's fucking right!
Grab!
I will grab you for the rest of my life!
Get over here!
Oh no, fuck.
I messed that up, oops.
Oh, what?
No.
You have to let me grab you.
That's right!
One more grab!
I'm too big to dash!
I'm way too fucking big to dash!
Just grab and dash as a fucking walk to the park!
Oh my god.
Alright.
I don't remember the other.
What were the other?
Oh, this one.
Up triangle.
I don't remember up triangle.
Run.
Grab.
I'm too swole!
I'm too swole to do it!
Okay.
Back.
You need a jump.
Alright.
Thank you.
Guys, one more.
Okay, I'll do the character guide after I do one more rank match.
I want a place.
Remember, you can jump forward.
I can jump forward?
Wait, is it Gumi again?
Only I know.
Oh no, it's not.
Okay.
It's Brimo Bunny.
I know Gumi is playing her.
That's why I was like, is that her again?
Is she still...
Is she still inky?
Like...
Oh no.
That's fine.
Grab!
Oh shit.
He punished me.
Oh.
Oh shit, no.
I didn't mean to.
Please, let me grab you!
Nice.
Alright.
Now I did like 200 million.
Oh, do I get this out?
No!
She gets this!
Oh.
Alright, nice.
I blocked it off.
Oh.
Alright, come on.
Come on.
No!
Come on!
Let me grab you!
No!
You're so close!
She wouldn't let me grab you!
I just wanna grab!
No!
Okay, that's good.
That's good!
I got the thing I wanted to do!
Nice!
Get countered!
No!
Okay.
Come on.
Come on!
Yes!
Okay.
You can't dodge this, bitch!
That's fucking right!
You can't get this!
You're on a win streak!
Oh!
Too bad!
Too fucking bad!
Have the opponent's HP!
Get over here!
This is the only thing I know.
Oh no!
I messed it up!
No!
She got it before me!
Oh no!
Oh no, guys!
Guys, she knows!
She knows!
I had one!
She downloaded me!
She knows!
She knows that I don't know a lot of moves!
How did she figure it out?
Oh my god!
I don't understand!
How the fuck did she figure it out?
This is literally the only thing I can do.
No!
She thought faster!
She thought faster than me!
Who was that?
I became rookie.
Okay.
Alright.
What was it?
View tutorial?
Where is...
How do I...
No.
I don't want to fight.
Return to mode select.
Alright.
How do I...
Oh, character guides!
There it is.
Alright.
Yes.
I don't fucking know.
Alright.
How do I play this guy?
Continue to the next guy.
Double!
Alright.
What is that?
How do I do that?
Keep them locked down?
Yeah, but what's the move?
Wait, it doesn't even let me...
What?
What are the buttons?
Wait!
Throw an opponent...
What are the buttons?
How am I...
Guys, I told you I'm a speed reader.
Guys, I told you.
But what are the buttons?
What are the fucking buttons?
How do I do that?
Reigning is fundamental.
Behold the red cyclone.
A devastatingly powerful throw.
It reaches long and its damage is immense.
But like...
How do I...
Okay.
Okay, maybe not...
Okay, combo trials.
Maybe that's it.
Okay.
I'm just like... I don't...
What does that mean?
I don't just...
Okay.
Machine gun.
Where is it?
Where's the buttons?
RS?
Which one's RS?
What?
Okay.
Command list?
What's RS?
What's...
What the fuck is RS?
R3?
This?
Is this RS?
Is it...
Right...
Oh, right stick!
Then what do I do?
Wait.
Okay.
That's it.
Alright.
This.
Okay.
Alright.
I need help.
I don't know how to...
It doesn't show me the...
The buttons.
I...
I don't know what I'm doing.
Try... Oh, there we go.
Oh, thank god.
There we go.
What the fuck is yellow M?
The fuck is yellow M?
Okay.
Control settings.
X.
Okay.
Yellow M is X.
How do I show that?
How do I...
How does it show it?
Oh, medium.
Which one is medium?
Which...
Okay.
This is blue.
Red.
Yellow.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
You're not...
Exactly.
Okay, guys.
I need to grab...
I need to grab water.
I'll be right back.
Like, why is it not...
Why is it not shapes?
Why is it color?
I can't read color.
The fuck
is blue?
Give me...
Do I have to, like, write the color?
Don't get...
I need to get markers.
Guys, I need to get, like, markers.
And I need to color my controller stick.
I need to...
I need to color my...
My leverless controller.
So I can figure out what the fuck is blue.
Like...
Okay.
Blue is...
Blue is square.
Square.
Okay.
There we go.
How do I... What?
Okay.
This is... Not this?
No.
Oh, this is yellow!
Fuck!
X is yellow!
Okay.
X is yellow.
We're doing it.
Alright.
It's so difficult.
What the fuck is auto press button blue?
Okay.
Blue is...
Auto button press blue?
What the fuck is auto?
Is this?
Oh, auto!
I figured it out.
It's the auto button.
Nice.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Alright.
This is auto.
Nice.
We did it.
Oh, you mean I can just press this and just do all the combos?
It's over.
It's so over!
Wait...
I can literally press R2 and do the combos!
Oh my god.
This is...
I love modern Q... Okay, I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I can let the gameplay for me.
I love it.
Knowing that I know I know I'm ready I'm so ready oh she getting cut I saw something tell me she's getting coached on Keith I think she's the only person I That's why Ashley won.
She suffered so much emotional damage.
All I did was lose too.
I didn't even know about the triangle until now.
You actually hurt Bentley.
God, I love fighting games.
I'm so ready.
I'm so fucking ready.
Oh shit, I need to remember not to do that.
What is this?
Is it triangle?
Okay, it's triangle circle.
You see, this is why I went in with zero ego.
Like, I know my place in this game.
So I went in with zero ego.
Wait,
what?
Right triangle.
No I can't.
Where's right triangle?
Am I looking at the right same right?
Am I even looking at the same right?
I have zero LP.
Wait, how much LP is it to rank up?
That's right.
It's over for you, grandpa.
It's so over for you.
I learned about L2.
Wait, you're in Modern Controls 2?
Who let you be on Modern Controls?
Oh shit.
Nice!
Uh oh, not nice.
Not nice.
Come on, get it closer.
Get closer.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, stop getting closer.
Stop getting closer.
Yes!
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Whoop!
Oh, come on.
That's fucking right.
That's right!
Get grabbed!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh.
Come on.
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
That's right.
Stop it.
Get punched!
He was red?
Oh!
Come on.
Oh, I'm fucked.
I'm so fucked.
Holy shit.
Oh yeah.
That's GG's.
That's GG's for me.
Oh my god.
I did a fucking Yamcha pose in the end.
I got demons so hard.
That's fucking right.
Grabbed!
Oh no.
Come on.
Come on!
Haha!
And then...
Grab!
That's fucking right.
Hahaha.
Oh no.
JK.
Hahaha.
Oh no.
JK.
Wait, how does that do nothing?
Big damage!
Oh!
That's right.
No win streak for you.
You're the second person I beat today.
Hahaha.
You're...
You're the second person I beat today.
Hahaha.
That's fucking right.
He lost his win streak on a guy that's only won two games.
Hahaha.
Yeah, I think I like Keef.
It's been pretty fun.
Oh, I beat three people today.
Okay, you guys know damn well that if you go fast, fast, parry, press parry and dash.
Guys, this is my dash.
This is how Keef dashes.
Hahaha.
Little hop.
Little bunny hop.
Hahaha.
Bunny hop.
Hold parry and then dash.
Oh my god, this is over.
I learned to move faster.
It's so over.
I learned to move even faster.
Oh my god.
From little bunny hop to fucking manly hop.
The bear runs.
Alright.
I wonder why does anybody want to queue into me?
Guys, why doesn't anybody want to queue into me?
Alright, you know what?
I know what to do.
It's time.
Hahaha.
Okay, one on one.
Singles.
Get in here.
Hahaha.
I'm on the left.
Get in here.
Wait, passcode off?
Wait, how do I make a passcode?
Wait, JK, sorry.
Not yet.
I just realized that I didn't even make a passcode.
Alright, give me a sec.
Hahaha.
Okay, I'll figure this out.
Oh wait, no.
That's not it.
Create room.
How the fuck role setting?
Role setting.
Uhhhh.
One, one, one, one, one.
There you go.
How do you guys get in?
Anyway, like, create room.
Is that it?
Alright, it's over.
Alright guys, get in here.
Hahaha.
I'll show you the power.
Wait, you're diamond.
Wait, not there.
But not there though.
Get in here.
Okay, that's a lot better.
Hahaha.
Bro, he's fucking diamond.
Like, I'm not gonna win against that.
Hahaha.
I'm not.
I'm not gonna win against that.
Watch this.
I learned how to play today.
Oh, yeah.
You got it.
Imagine being...
Oh, shit.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, ma'am.
Oh, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
Ma'am.
Let me have a hit, ma'am.
Hahaha.
Holy shit.
Okay.
We gotta figure this out.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay.
I let her win.
I let her have that one win, guys.
Like...
It's okay.
She's on fucking classic.
It's over for her.
Like, the moment I figured this out, it's so over.
Like...
Guys, I'll get out of this corner and it's gonna be so over.
I swear... Okay.
Hahaha.
Guys, I was just going easy.
I was just...
I was just... I was going easy on him.
I wanted people to, you know, oh my god.
Why are you on me?
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, new challenger.
Hey!
You don't have a rank.
Hahaha.
You don't have...
You're new.
I'm new.
We can both be new together.
We can...
We can both be new.
Funny fact.
Okay.
Hahaha.
No way.
People smurfing in video games?
That's against the laws.
No way.
Who would do such a thing?
Who would... Who would fucking do such a thing?
Wait.
He's dodging everything.
Are you... Are you lying on the internet?
Hahaha.
Wait.
You don't seem new.
Hahaha.
I see dodging.
Guys.
Guys, I don't think he's new.
I don't think he's new.
Guys, I can't grab him at all.
He won't...
He won't let me grab.
It's so cruel.
He's not letting me grab.
Hahaha.
Guys.
I can't do anything.
Hahaha.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he lied.
Hahaha.
Wait.
You're new.
Okay.
You're clearly not new, guys.
Guys, get out.
Hahaha.
Wait.
You're iron.
Let me fight the iron player.
I wanna fight the iron player.
I...
Hahaha.
Okay.
Don't worry.
This guy is platinum.
He can't be that good.
There's no way.
Wait.
You can make faces?
Oh.
You can make faces.
Large black bear.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
The training montage begins.
Good luck, Doki.
It's okay.
There's no way she knows that, like, all I know how to do is grab.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Like, my secret is safe.
There's no way.
There's no way she knows that.
The moment I learn how to move, there's no...
The moment I can, like...
The moment I can touch her!
Hahaha.
Please let me...
Fuck you, whore.
Hahaha.
Oh, I didn't mean it.
I was joking.
I...
I'm sorry!
Please let me fucking do something!
Hahaha.
How did...
What?
What is she doing?
Oh.
Wait, did I... No, I can't even grab her!
Please.
Let me just...
Please just let me... Please just let me grab you.
Please, that's all I ask!
Hahaha.
That's all I ask.
Please.
No!
Okay, I got the grab.
I got the grab, guys.
I did it.
I... Guys.
I got another grab, guys!
I did it.
I got another grab.
Oh my god.
I got...
I got another grab!
Bro, Jesus, please.
There's no way.
Hahaha.
I might as well have won.
Guys, I got a grab.
It's the moral victory of that.
Hahaha.
It's...
I got the grab.
I... I got the grab.
I...
How do I kick people out?
Okay.
Guys, can I...
Guys, can I get any...
Oh, please.
How do I...
Hahaha.
I won't bother you.
Don't keep trust.
How do I kick people out?
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It can't be that bad.
She's clearly new at this character.
Like...
The other guy, they know how to play this character.
This guy, she's clearly new.
She's clearly new at this character, right?
Surely.
Surely, right?
This person doesn't know how to play her, right?
Oh my god, please.
Hahaha.
Please.
There's no way.
Yeah, that's actually right.
Oh, he doesn't know how to play her.
Wait, this is it.
She doesn't know how to play her.
I figured it out.
Wait.
He doesn't know how to play her.
Wait, this is it.
He's actually new.
There's hope.
Hahaha.
There's actual hope.
I can actually win.
Oh my god.
A new player.
Fresh meat.
Just do a few punches.
But what punch when I can grab?
Grab.
Come on.
Hahaha.
What will she possibly...
Grab.
What will she do?
Will she grab?
Why punch when I can grab?
Exactly.
Oh no.
She's doing that thing.
But I can do things too.
No, I can't.
Oh, what?
Why?
Hahaha.
Who can tell what Toki, the grappling master, will do next?
That's not fair.
He's using range.
That should be illegal.
How do I grab something that has range?
That's fucking right.
Anti-air.
Jump again, bitch.
Hahaha.
That's like, do it again.
Oh, yeah?
Did you want to...
Hahaha.
That's fucking right.
Whoa.
There we go.
We beat one dragoon today.
That's all that matters.
Oh my god, an iron player.
Let's go.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Their actual bad play is just like me.
I win.
Let's go.
What will I do?
What would I do?
Oh, shit.
The grab master.
Come on.
Get over here.
Hahaha.
What would I possibly do?
Oh my god.
It's such a mystery.
Hahaha.
What a mystery.
What would I possibly do?
Hahaha.
Easy.
What would she do?
Thanks.
No one can predict this mixup.
Fucking mixup, guys.
Oh.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Jump up.
Hahaha.
What would I possibly do next?
We'll never know.
Oh my god.
What's that?
A punch?
Hahaha.
Okay.
Oh my god.
In another way.
What?
How are you ironed?
How the fuck are you ironed?
Hahaha.
How are you fucking ironed?
Bro.
Bro, I...
Hahaha.
No way.
I should be ironed.
I should be fucking ironed.
Why the fuck am I a rookie?
Here comes a new challenger.
Hahaha.
She isn't ironed.
He's new.
Is he actually new?
There's no way.
He actually has to be new.
Whoa.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Look, iron is pretty good.
It's iron is...
Iron is better than...
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but iron is like better than...
Oh shit.
Oh.
Come on.
No, come on.
Is that fair?
You're supposed to be new at this game.
What are you doing?
Hahaha.
Come on.
Let me grab you.
Just let me grab you one time.
Please.
That's fucking right, bitch.
Why you let me grab you, huh?
You let me grab you, you're a bad player.
Hahaha.
Oh shit.
I'm sorry.
I'm the bad player.
Whoops.
Hahaha.
Guys, this guy is not new.
This guy is not new.
He lie.
No.
That's right.
I have auto combos.
Come on.
Let me use my auto combos.
Yes.
Down you go.
And I can do it.
I can't do it again.
Oh no.
I'm dizzy.
Whoa.
No.
Do the thing.
Guys.
Guys, I don't think he's new.
What the fuck am I doing?
What the fuck was that?
Please.
If you let me grab, it'll be so funny.
That's all right.
You know it'll be so funny.
He doesn't like funny.
Oh.
Wait.
All right.
Since you're on gif, it's fine.
Okay.
Who's gonna be the better gif?
Me who just learned how to play two hours ago?
Or this guy?
There's no way.
Like, how does he know more gif than I?
I have two hours of gif.
Wait.
He threw me.
What?
I wanna throw.
Wait.
He threw me again.
How does he get that before I do?
Come on.
What?
This is not fair.
Wait.
Use classic controls, you bitch.
I thought you were supposed to be a FGC player.
Why are you using modern?
Dang.
Wait.
How does he do that?
You
did it.
That's right.
You already got one grab in.
It's already too late.
It's already embarrassing for you.
It's already embarrassing to you.
You did it.
That's the key word.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I regret.
Not even a double perfect.
She's kofing.
All I'm saying, it wasn't even a double perfect.
Alright.
This person has to be new, right?
He has to be new.
There's no way.
There's no way I'm fighting two smurfs at the same time.
Yeah.
How could you fumble so hard, man?
How could you fumble that?
Oh no.
He punished me.
Okay.
It's okay.
I got the grab.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Dodge.
This is what I learned.
I've taken your stride and made it my own.
Easy.
I've absorbed the skill.
That's the way.
He was teaching.
I learned.
I fucking learned.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
That's not right.
Oh no.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
I downloaded it.
I realize all I have to do...
Get closer.
Come on.
Get over here.
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Come on.
Don't do that again.
Oh.
Missed.
No.
I missed.
My turn.
Easy.
That's so easy.
Look at that.
I figured it out.
I'm a natural.
Literally ran her like a buck.
Look.
No.
Oh my god.
What can I say?
I think... I think I'm a gamer guys.
I think I'm...
I think that...
I think we're gonna have two geese.
I think we're gonna have two geese in the team.
Toki, this is robbery.
She can't keep getting away with this.
Ruin, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'll see you guys.
I'll do one last.
We'll call it one last ranked game.
I'm feeling confident.
Right here.
I'm feeling so confident.
Not team pro pro three kings again.
Yeah.
But then we're gonna have two geese at least.
I beat the goons.
If I can beat the goons, I can beat the world.
How are you gonna counter me?
How?
I hope we get three geese.
That would be so fucking funny.
I hope.
I do hope we do get three geese.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Like I know all the moves that I have to know.
Triangle.
Left triangle.
And then...
No.
Don't say that.
There's nobody smart enough to use JP.
Don't fucking say that.
Don't...
Guys.
I'm not...
I'm not Doki Bird.
Do you not see my name?
It says not Doki Bird.
Sorry.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
Guys.
It says...
It says not Doki Bird.
So that means I'm not learning geese.
No.
She's not gonna learn JP.
She says she wants to learn foot lady.
If she backs out on foot lady, she's a fucking coward.
She's a fucking coward.
Okay.
Whoa.
Come on.
Wait.
How does she know?
How does he know that that's all I wanted?
JK.
You didn't know bitch.
You didn't.
Oh my god.
He actually knows.
No you don't.
Oh shit.
Unless.
That's fucking right.
You don't know.
Oh no.
I'm too tired.
Oh I'm so tired.
But it's okay.
You're down.
Get out.
I punched.
Holy shit.
She can learn.
The mix up.
Guys.
The mix up is that I start punching.
Imagine.
The mix up.
The punch mix up.
The punch mix up is gonna be fucking wild guys.
Get off of me.
That's fucking right.
Get down.
You think you own the skies?
No skies for you.
Oh.
There's no way he defends that.
Yes.
She thinks she's.
Let's go.
Get out.
You can't fly.
Oh shit.
You don't need to fly apparently.
Oh.
What the fuck.
That's fucking right.
Get down.
Come on.
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
Get out.
Yeah.
I think I'm gonna be a geek player.
Little air superiority.
I was the master jury at the bottom.
Was hoping to fight.
But alright.
Good luck with your street fighter 6 journey.
Thank you for the super chat cake.
This is why you did not fight me.
The master jury.
This is exactly why.
I'm literally in rookie.
I'm not here.
I'm not here to get fucking beat up.
Okay.
That was fun.
That was fun for the first street fighter.
That was really fun for the first street fighter.
Street fighter 6 stream.
I...
Yeah.
You need a smurf.
Wait.
To make sure we...
Alright.
Let's see.
To make sure that everybody knows that...
Okay.
Let's see.
How do I change my profile?
Okay.
Triangle.
How do I do that?
Wait.
How do I change my profile?
I need people to know.
I need people to know what I'm playing.
There's no way they'll find out, right?
There's no way.
There's no way they'll know.
There's no way they'll know who I'm gonna play.
How do I change my name?
Guys, how do I change my name, chat?
Change your selected kick.
Go under.
What the fuck?
Oh, is it this?
CFN?
Oh.
Okay.
Players Rankings.
Is that it?
Oh, it's in main settings?
Okay.
Let's see.
Multi-menu.
Options.
What do I do?
Oh, there you go.
Not do...
Dogeef.
There you go.
Don't ever know.
I'm not.
It's not.
Not do...
Not.
Nobody will know.
Do I do dogeef or dogeef, guys?
Is it dogeef or... Should I do dogeef or dogeef?
Totally not a geef teaser.
Don't ever know.
How would they know?
Dogeef or dogeef?
Okay, we'll make a poll.
We'll make a poll chat.
Dogeef or dogeef?
Dogeef.
There you go.
Alright, you guys get to decide my...
By watching the clip.
What clip?
Do not delete.
I won't delete the VOD.
Archives your VOD.
Oh my god.
If I just do...
If I just do like do Honda and then just play away.
That's so good.
Okay.
They'll never know.
They'll think I'm a Honda player.
The mixup.
Exactly.
Yes!
They'll never know.
They'll think I'm a Honda player.
Honda key.
No, do Honda.
Do Honda or do...
Honda key.
Honda key or do Honda.
Honda honkey.
No, no, not honkey.
Now you're good.
Yes!
I mean, it's like reverse psychology.
It says not.
So then they'll be like...
Oh, she's not.
You know?
It'll say like...
Honda.
Honda key.
We're not doing honkey.
Oh my god.
What if we do honkey?
The actual mixup.
No, actually do Honda.
We'll do do Honda.
Honda key.
Honda bird.
Wait!
No, okay.
Do Honda.
We'll do do Honda.
God, that's so hard to pick.
It's so hard.
All of them are such good names.
They're all such good names.
Do Honda.
Alright,
Honda bird.
Honkey bird.
Okay.
Honda key.
No, do Honda.
Not do Honda.
Not do...
No, not...
Not honkey.
Is that honkey bird?
Uh...
Honda.
No, Honda doesn't sound good.
Yeah, not do Honda.
There we go.
They're all good.
They're all so good.
Not gonna lie.
But I had a great time.
It was a great learning experience.
Figuring out my main throughout that journey.
I had a great time figuring out my main.
We did it, guys.
We fucking did it.
But yeah.
Honestly, I hope BroadPro and I get the our coach pick.
Because we know for sure we're gonna be on the same team.
And we're both gonna be key players.
Sorry, we're both gonna be Honda players.
So, when are teams gonna be announced?
I believe, like, is it this week?
I don't know.
I didn't pay much attention.
Okay, Wednesday.
It's on Wednesday.
It's on...
They're announcing it on Wednesday.
So, um...
You already saw...
Guys, you already saw my speed reading today.
Um...
But yeah, it's been really fun playing Street Fighter for the very first time.
And I'm looking...
I'm honestly looking forward to the real TokiBeard.
Oh my god, there's the real TokiBeard.
There she is.
Not like that poser.
Not TokiBeard.
Anyway, Wednesday would be the team announcement.
So, we'll see who we get.
I'm gonna request Brian.
Bravo and I are both gonna request Brian.
So, we'll see if we do get Brian.
Like, I mean, Brian could just, you know, reject me.
Cause they're like... He's like, I don't wanna coach fucking...
Like...
Like, Brian sees this VOD and he's like, no, she's...
she's hopeless.
Like, this would mean I'll get Brian.
Um... But yeah, it was great.
I had a great time.
It was really fun.
Um, as always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye-bye.